-We don't always
have enough time
to cover all of the recent news,
so here with a recap
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You guys!
Things have been crazy!
Okay, first of all,
everyone was like,
"Look at this cow."
And I was like, "What?"
But then I saw the whole picture
and was like, "Whaaaat?!"
What does that cow eat?
Other cows?
Then, on Twitter, Trump referred
to himself as "President T."
And I was like, "What?"
The only way we'll have
a President T
is if this guy runs in 2020.
Trump also said that
people told him
he's like Elvis,
and I was like, "What?!"
The only way you're like Elvis
is that you
will likely die on a toilet.
But not for 100 years,
because it never ends with you.
Then something
hilarious happened.
Okay, a super far-right woman
named Laura Loomer
got banned from Twitter
and then handcuffed herself
to Twitter headquarters
to protest.
And I was like, "What?
She's going to get in
so much trouble."
But then Twitter was like,
"Who cares?"
Police came, cut her free,
and Twitter didn't even
press charges.
I was like, "What?!"
Girl, you handcuffed yourself
to the thing you hate
for no reason.
Also, look at this.
She only handcuffed herself
to one door.
You're supposed to chain
yourself to both doors
so they can't open them.
Otherwise,
you're just a doorman.
Then the national dog show
happened, and it was beautiful.
It was fluffy little "what"
after fluffy little "what"
after fluffy little "what."
Oh, it was great until one of
handlers ate his dog's treat.
Look.
-Standard wants you to take
a good look this breed.
-[ Laughs ]
I was like, "What?!"
That doggy worked hard
for that treat, and you ate it.
That doggy stood still
while a stranger
touched his little doggy balls
and judged them.
He deserves a treat.
You ate dog food as a grown man
on national television.
Instead of how I did --
as a child, on a dare.
Then the Crown Prince
of Saudi Arabia
had a journalist murdered,
and then he thought
he could just show up to
the G20 Summit this week
and be friends with everybody.
But when it came time
for handshakes,
all the other world leaders
were like, "Nope.
No. Nope. No. No."
Yeah, it's hard being
a murderer.
Then a woman got mad at
Southwest Airlines
because the ticket agent made
fun of her child's name.
Her child's name, Abcde,
spelled A-B-C-D-E.
And I was like, "W-H-A-T?!"
This poor child. Abcde.
Of course your child
got made fun of at Southwest.
You named her after
their boarding zones.
You know what kind of pain
this child will have?
I do because my middle name
is Mildred.
A-B-C-D-E-F that.
Then Ivanka Trump
was asked recently about how
she used her
personal e-mail account
to send official
White House e-mails.
But I did not hear her answer
because I was like,
"What is this lighting?"
Is this an interview
or is she in an old Disney movie
with flying, talking
magic birds?
She is literally glowing.
But, you know, I can't relate.
I don't need special effects
to look good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All I need is
five professional adults.
They're so tired.
Oh, you know what?
I think I get it.
Is it that you think
soft lighting
makes unpleasant things
easier to hear?
Hmm. Let me try.
Ivanka, I believe you
to be complicit
in the destruction
of our nation.
-And your dad is a dick.
-That's right, birdie.
-This has been
"Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪